I usually Victoria Elena I usually
Victoria Elena take the jab Christopher
stand the jack krzyston to my wedded
husband
Princess Eugenie and Jack Brooksbank
tied the knot at st. George's Chapel and
the guest list was stacked with a slew
of famous friends and family Sarah
Ferguson has an incredible contacts but
both in the UK and overseas in the u.s.
there's a guest list of 850 people 400
of those will be going on to the evening
party but that celebrity cohort those a
listers very much friends of the couple
but also friends of sarah's megan merkel
was a vision in this navy dress in cope
by Givenchy as her hubby Prince Harry
Prince su Ginny's cousin sat beside her
in a black suit Prince Harry's ex
Chelsea Davy was also on the guest list
Kate Middleton and Prince William
quickly headed inside after being driven
to the chapel door taking their seats
next to Harry and Megan the couple who
Wed in 2011 even snuck in some
hand-holding before the ceremony began
there's Prince George and Princess
Charlotte who were as cute as ever
serving in Eugenie's bridal party and
that's Kate's sister Pippa Middleton
showing off her baby bump in an
evergreen number Cara Delevingne arrived
at the castle in a suit and top hat and
there's Liv Tyler who looked chic in
navy Naomi Campbell sported a dress by
Ralph Andrew so Kate Mosse stunned in
polka dots with her 16 year old daughter
Lila grace Moss hack by her side well
Demi Moore rocked a dark red dress by
Stella McCartney before the big day
royal expert Katie Nicol dish to ET on
Damis royal connection
we know that Demi Moore is very tight
with the mother of the bride Sarah
Ferguson and Demi Moore was spotted here
Londyn just the other day shopping in
Notting Hill with Kate Moss Kate Moss
and Naomi Campbell two big names both of
course famous supermodels who are also
expected to be on that guest list
James Blunt Ellie Goulding Ricky Martin
and Robbie Williams were also present
for the nuptials not in attendance
however George and Amal Clooney and
Victoria and David Beckham who were all
predicted to come George and Amal are
close friends of Jack and moschini Jack
works for George's tequila company Casa
Mika's which is also leading to a lot of
speculation that Randy Gerber and Cindy
Crawford will also be at this wedding
George is actually expected at varieties
power of women event in Los Angeles
where he will present an award to
parkland school shooting survivor and
March for our lives activist Emma
Gonzales
[Music]